um yeah yeah
my name is iman mosawat i work for asmr
research
i work mostly on optical metrology
that's where you hit some very small
target with light
and you look at the response of the
target to light and from that you try to
infer what you're looking at so you fit
some model to the data you look into
patterns of how targets are excited with
light and a lot of
uh
it's essentially an area where physics
uh signal processing and
statistical inference come into together
yes so give a warm applause please
[Applause]
so this goes
yes so i'm going to talk about
compressive sensing um
this is uh if you have especially if you
have a high-end digital camera the dslr
you see that your sensor produces
really large images raw images maybe 30
40
megabytes and then you can compress them
into order kilobytes
and that allows us to transmit things
very fast
so
um
the point is that if you could have such
a successful compression you if you want
to wear a
rather pessimistic view of it is a
failure of sensor design in a way so so
you've measured a lot of things that
you're going to discard later
right so it's actually the success
that's the issue
depending on how you look at it and
then this becomes an issue when
resources are scarce so if you have a
big dslr
you don't have a problem but there are
many cases where this becomes a problem
uh so this is a compressed sensing where
not only now you um
not only now you sense things but you're
also compressing right so your your
sensing hardware is compressing your
data
it doesn't really
measure
the object it it measures certain type
of information about the object that is
already compressed
and then you have to actually do an um
an act of reconstruction that is harder
than um essentially
decompression here so here you have a
large number and then you go to a small
number but here you you already have
that
okay so this is compressive sensing so
essentially going right in the hardware
and changing the hardware such that you
measure in a compressed way
why that matters so an example is mri so
you can have an
application uh such as a pediatric
cases where your patient is
non-cooperative you will wobble a lot in
this mri it would blur the image so you
cannot tell them to just hold their
breasts for two minutes that's not gonna
work so
they're lowering the times that that the
resource you want to save is time
okay so you cannot put your camera on
the tripod and wait here you don't have
that time so you can go from
order minutes
to order seconds that really opened a
whole new application how you do it
mri measures a fourier transform of a
signal yes basically just looking what
kind of
signs and cosigns are in your signal
and each of them is like a 2d fourier
transform and mri measures the whole
thing but now we just sub-sampled it
right so we measure lower frequencies a
lot and like randomly measuring high
frequency without any pattern actually
it shouldn't have a pattern as a matter
of fact so it should be random which is
also a bit strange
but
now essentially simply by measuring less
you can save time and later you have you
you spend time on processing things
another example is a more constructive
example you
you have this object say l this object
itself is sparse so k is the number of
non-zero elements everything else is
zero
this line is a measurement mechanism so
you multiply this by a random pattern
that's what comes out this is masking
and then you look into how many bright
pixels come out and that's your
measurements
so that's one measurement it's not
measure each measurement could have been
a pixel so if this random pattern was
one pixel this would have been a pixel
value and then you need it for every
pixel you did the measurement but now
the measurements are
mixing signal from many different pixels
right so you can have different other
different random patterns so every
column is a different measurements right
so
in this case
m is the number of measurements so the
number of columns you have k is the
number of non-zero elements so how many
elements are carrying information
and n is the total space that you're
looking at so the number of pixels
another example
is uh more common maybe in data science
is more a data sciencey is in painting
so you have a full matrix and you can
simply save time by not measuring every
year so by mixing some of these pixels
this is
an example that you see a lot in
recommender systems
where you have a
big matrix that's incomplete right so
you have seen some of the movies but
there are movies you're interested but
you didn't see
and essentially by feeling that matrix
you're gonna guess whether you would be
interested in a certain movie yes or no
so there would be for example different
movies and different people and you
would have a
empty matrix or or a very sparsely
filled matrix that you will fill in it's
the same thing as in painting
and that problem also appears here so
that's a mathematical problem here you
also may want to avoid some measurement
of some of these pixels so your your
hardware is built such that you just sub
sample
so so far the summary is that
compressive sensing shifts the
complexity from sensors hardware to
algorithms so you would have cheaper
hardware faster hardware you would kind
of save time on the operation of the
hardware and then you do things
in the
computing infrastructure this is um
later in the application i can talk a
little bit about it this can create kind
of the market it can affect the risk of
potential competition so people can come
with weaker sensors and stop competing
with you by more heavier algorithms
uh depending on the application gains
can be from two to ten times tenfold
right
so
uh mri i as i mentioned i have
talked about it the internet of things
is another one so you can have a ton of
sensors all over they don't have a lot
of power
and uh this that's their the resource
you want to
essentially
save and for example if you don't have a
lot of pixels if you don't use your
analog to digital converter a lot
because analog to digital conversion
wastes a lot of energy
so if you could use that less you would
reduce the energy consumption super
resolution is exactly the other
direction here you're gonna
take your time you're gonna measure more
such that you can increase your
resolution so now you can have
microscopes that go beyond the physical
limits of a microscope can do
uh by measuring more right so then now
you're essentially
trading off
temporal
resolution how fast you can measure with
a spatial resolution how
close you can measure that's the type of
um
trade-off you're going to make here
okay um the two pillars of
compressive sensing is a prior knowledge
so this should be very
well known in this community i think and
in coherent measurement by inquiring i
don't mean it in the optical sense if
you happen to have that background
incoherent means that you're gonna just
like this example with the l you're
gonna you're gonna not measure pixel by
pixel but you're gonna measure a whole
lot of things in one shot together right
um
if there is a time at the end that will
talk about the example of incoherent
measurement at the end but
for now
think about that example with the l
where you don't measure measure mix of
different aspects of the signal every
time
so prior knowledge the field that
started with the sparsity became
official compressive sensing as part of
it this is a very old technique this
goes i think maybe 70s or so
in around 2006 there was a mathematical
breakthrough that they could prove
theorems
about the performance of this so it
became official field but it was there
for a very long time people just didn't
know how it works right so then there
were guarantees came forward
and now today we go
beyond this assumption of sparsity to
generative models we push performance
forward using deep learning but as usual
we lose all um
yeah we lose we don't know really again
how it works so we go back to the 30
years ago right so when we know how deep
learning works and we would also get our
guarantees back but uh
that's the situation
so these are the two pillars let me
explain this parsley a little bit
so
if you have a signal f
you can have a representation of it x
that is essentially a representation if
psi here is
depending on what this matrix is for
example this can be a bunch of sines and
cosines in this rows then
you can get a fourier transform here
right
or
this can be wavelets and you get a
wavelet transform so this is your signal
of interest this is this the
representation of that
and here you
imagine this signal f where in the
fourier domain is very sparse it just
have a few
spikes
right
the sparse means zero in some
representation apart from a few values
now suppose i'm going to sample it in a
very irregular grid right in a very
irregular way
and from that can i reconstruct
right okay so if i now reconstruct of at
least the squares this is a linear
problem as as i can show
if you do it with lisa scores you is
completely messed up so if you if you
sample
irregular in a
not with the right frequency which would
be your nyquist frequency then you can't
reconstruct but if you now tell him this
was a sparse signal in the fourier
domain you can exactly reconstruct
so without any error right
so that's actually the the the
great thing about it
um
but
in reality signals are not generally
sparse you cannot find a representation
that this is especially when i saw the
title of the previous talk uh
working in in theory and
broken in reality i thought that's
really ironic that that's just before
this talk so but
but this is really the case so signal is
a power law so so things are not really
a delta function and a few nonzero
values you get these histograms where
you have a lot of small big values but
you also have a lot of small values that
are not ignorable right you don't have
only zeros and big values
so
so that's that's the reality of it
um
now
if i go to the sensing problem so what
this hardware does i can also think of
sensing also as a linear operator and
depending of the hardware you can
find what linear operator it is so for
example if phi is sinusoids then we are
sensing in the fourier dom and then you
build a nice mri
right
if phi is integrating the signal over
the area of pixels then you've pixelated
so maybe you have a ccd and if you have
super pixels then that's another example
right so essentially what this does in
some very um crude way can be a linear
operation
so
and here is the whole thing so
your your actual signal by some linear
operation goes to this y
then this signal can have a
representation
so you can put these two equations all
in all and
this is the measurement values you get
out of this
sensing problem and you have to come up
with x
you know phi and psi so at the end
compressive sensing just solve a linear
problem so there hasn't been any
breakthrough in in linear algebra for
for i think decades or maybe a century
and then suddenly in 2006 a
mathematician of the first grade and
actually a few of them they figure that
this is actually an interesting problem
and they find out exactly that you can
exactly solve this when you don't have
enough equations right so that's the
whole point you don't have enough
equations because this a is short and
fat so
you get a very long signal egg a very
large number of the entries here and
just a few elements there that's the
that's a catch
again if i look into this example what
you have here is that
if i just want to map it to the
equations i show you here psi is the
identity matrix because the signal
itself is a sparse so you don't have to
go to a transformation
this
mass phi is randomized right so
and a is just fine okay
so essentially in a nutshell you solve a
linear system
where essentially the number of
measurements and the number of unknowns
are are not matched you have way more
unknowns and measurements
the the trick is that you a is just not
a mathematical thing is desi is forced
by your hardware
so so you your hardware is dictating
part of this
and that is a kind of a big deal and
then not every a allows you to to to to
work so if signals are apart from each
other in the x domain when a is applied
they should still be apart from each
other
afterwards they call it restricted
isometry property rip and that's it the
type of things that the mathematician
will come up with rip but basically it
says
an example is that if you have
completely random matrix
you need a certain number of
measurements and this number of
measurements just grows logarithmically
with number of pixels this is fantastic
so if you order a million um
pixels this is like a log million right
this is becomes a six or so so it's of
course this is just a bound but it's
very very scaling very nicely with n it
sketches linearly with k and that's the
number of non-zero elements in your
representation so you at least have to
have that many
um
if you want to try something in psychic
learn i will as i show you
shortly
if you solve l1 reconstruction problem
you essentially can do this so l1
parallelization uh is the the the kind
of prior you use for compressive sensing
and l2 finalization is uh the standard
regression which you see that in this
case where you have a very sparse signal
it really doesn't work but for l1
pronunciation it does work very nicely
what you see here
is that this problem that we want to
solve so you want to find x such that y
equal to x and
the l zero norm is minimum l zero norm
is the number of non-zero elements this
is a nightmare to solve because you have
to find which subset is
which substance should be non-zero
everything is zero and it's a kind of
the
np-hard problem
so as long when x grows you're hopeless
right you put your gpus you just grow
linearly in front of this
it would dwarf you this means that it's
just finding a needle in a big haystack
right
it needs resources
um
and if you have enough measurements and
that's the mathematical breakthrough in
2006 then you can solve another problem
you can solve the l one norm problem
instead of finding a zero norm and l one
norm means that just take the absolute
values of the entries of x sum them up
and this should be minimum and this
happens to be
to give you the exact solution of the
very difficult problem so you saw in
linear time so in polynomial time so in
polynomial time you can solve this
problem you get exact solution the catch
is that you need this many certain
number of measurements
and a has to have this restricted
isometric property so this was this
means that you still find the needle in
the haystack it's just a very big needle
right so
uh
so if i want to
look in this direction
so if i don't have enough measurements
if my number of measurements less than
my number of non-zero elements
essentially i'm looking for a black cat
in the dark room right it's what you
call overfitting right you just find
something because you have the complex
model and not enough evidence
this is impossible in the information
theoretic cells you can just not do that
if you
have enough measurements so if the
moment m passes k
you go through a phase transition
suddenly now you can find it it's just
very hard to find it so there is no
polynomial time to algorithm to do this
and if you have even more at some point
you will go through a second phase
transition which allows you then to
actually solve it efficient efficiently
now why this is so
important
this is important because it tells us
what is a hard problem it matters two
very different fields one is about
computational complexity and big o
notation people that things that people
do in computer science which i know not
so much actually about it and one is
about statistics information theory
right where there is more information it
has an impact on
the the numerical complexity so it
brings really these two fields
close to each other which is a very
phenomenal thing by the way this has
nothing to do with only comprehensive
sensing is a global phenomena
we have seen many many problems they
have this control parameter wherever you
increase you first
go from impossible to
possible but very hard and then easy
um so this is the again k divided by n
is uh is is your uh
probability of nonzero values m divided
by n is the measurement rate and you see
this different phase transition for
different type of signals so the signals
we are discussing here is just sparse
signals and so for a certain rate
certain number of k divided by n you
have to go here and see how many
measurements you need relatively such
that it works
um and this has a very interesting
related with statistical physics i'm not
a physicist by the way but i just i'm
always fascinated by physics so um
the same mathematics that governs why uh
things are in in liquid state when
they're warm and then you can get this
cool supercooled
state and then go to the solid state has
the same mathematics that you have
in algorithms and the mathematics behind
it is free energy so if you have worked
with variational autoencoder you're
actually having bounds that are
approximating this and that's the
mathematics that is governing all of
this
[Music]
so
here is a
histogram of the number of non-zero
elements so how rich is the signal and
you see that signals are not the sparse
you can have even 60
non-zero elements
right so this means that you need you
would need a lot of measurements to
measure them
so
if i go to this curve and say okay i
just have a signal that has 20 non-zero
you already need half of
half the number of pixels you need
measurements so it's not that good
actually in practice right so it's all
very nice and sexy at some point you can
exactly reconstruct but at which point
that point can actually be not so great
so for a relatively sparse signal that
just non zero twenty percent of the time
you have to still measure half of the
time you just can get the factor two
improvement not so great right so then
this is what l1 norm does and this is
what a more complicated prior does for
you so you can use neural network to
create more complex prior instead of
saying that hey i have a signal that in
some transformed domain is mostly zero
you can say i have certain nonlinear
manifold that i'm going to learn that
from the data
and my signal is on that manifold so
find the point on that manifold that
give you my this type of mixed
measurements and then you can see
something that elven totally failed
they can work and then this is
variational autoencoder and then you can
have even fancier methods like
uncertainty autoencoder that is matched
to this problem
with information theoretical
reasoning to to work much better so you
can go below and here you actually
pumped more information to your problem
so um
here so this is a bunch of different
algorithms but i'm going in to the next
slide and just basically say
in lots of applications right so you
have a lot of field knowledge you know a
lot about your your domain
but now these days people say oh give me
a lot of data and i'm going to ignore
that so the whole thing is to come with
this
best of both worlds strategy where you
use your field knowledge but you're also
using data together and that's actually
the evolution that you see in the in the
methods that are used for compressive
sensing so people started with model
agnostic methods
when they tried to use deep learning and
here you have data extensive method you
have low bias you have flexible neural
networks that do
reconstruction for you
but they have no clue that they're
actually solving an non-a compressive
sensing problem you don't use anything
about what you know about comprehensive
sensing on the other have case you have
a simple model that is based on a
sparsity so it's really heavily
based on what you know in this there is
a domain in which your signal is the
sparse and so on and so forth
so and then interesting thing is that
there are mix of this so here you have
more complex priors than the sparsity
for example you say
that
wavelets are
have certain properties
and in the mix here you have neural
networks whose architecture is designed
based on
compressive sensing algorithms this is
the last slide
this is there is an algorithm called
approximate message passing if you have
been working with probabilistic method
you have uh you know about belief
propagation that's a method is used
often on probabilistic graphs
um and amp is essentially belief
propagation on a steroid so it's a
it's kind of uh yeah
a very
fast approximation to to believe
propagation and
now we have
changed the equations of amp to fit a
neural network instead of these certain
equations so there are certain terms in
a amp
term in amp equations where we change
this very rigid term that is in the amp
algorithm we convert that
to
to
something that it can be learned by a
neural network and that works very good
so it's a mix of all the equations that
would work for amp that is designed to
solve a compressive sensing problem
but they are adjusted some terms in
those equations are adjusted to use a
neural network
instead of for example some operator
right and and then you get the best of
both worlds so you get a system for
example that you can if you change your
sensing matrix it will still work
uh and uh and you can see that
in terms of time to reconstruct is much
faster than the other things for
interference time
um and is psnr is better so this is a
different rates of measurements here you
measure 25 percent of time and tempers
of time so it measures faster
it measures um
it reconstructs faster it can work with
less number of measurements at a better
snr but there is no guarantee anymore so
you throw all the mathematics into a
trash can
uh that's a that's the sap so i hope
that changes and and and pretty much
that's it
so if there's any question i would be
glad to answer
[Applause]
are you true that i'm very bad
thanks for your presentation yes it was
a lot of information but i really liked
seeing a lot of things i have
seen coming passing by and now having
them all connected in the sense so
that's what i liked about the
presentation so thank you
if i understand correctly in compress
sensing you have some sparse domain that
you try to sample right and then you
have this one slide where you also
showed the digit data set and there you
also have this thing with the variation
of auto encoder because i think a lot of
neural networks also
if you bring your dimensions down in the
middle they also do some kind of
encoding so i wondered
how does that how does it actually work
because i i
in all the other compressed sensing you
kind of like
define your transformation from the
sparse domain to like the non-sparse
domain
yourself but now
with this one the neural network can
learn it or how does it yes so so so it
really depends on which one you you you
consider this i actually have uae in in
the back of my mind better
um so you remember that you pick some
transformation psi and that will give
you something that's a sparse right so
there is this domain either you go to
fourier domain or wavelet domain and by
magic you get something especially and
we know in reality that doesn't happen
right so let's train
a
a a a side that gives you something uh
very effective and here they actually
have a cost function so they have a
uh
a kind of uh encoder decoder uh strategy
where the encoder is linear and the
decoder is non-linear
and the encoder works such that
given the encoder you have maximum
information about what is outside so the
the cost function is not minimizing msc
or so or or uh
other variational bound you try to
essentially say i'm going to find
directions that give you maximum
information about what came in
and then you use that to to to
essentially reconstruct
what is coming out so you you pick this
particular domain
yeah
okay thank you
oh yes and on the very back can you pass
it or i can bring it to you
yes
thanks
um
great presentation uh so you have these
uh slides where you have the kind of the
um
the two the extreme and uh all models in
between right oh yeah at the end the
last slide yes yes this one uh
so
maybe a question which part of the
spectrum would you recommend to be uh is
there a specific part that you say okay
this is you should always be here or it
depends on your application yes how
would you
yes it depends on the application so so
i think um
uh if if you're brave and you can take
the guarantees out and and pay
when you're in the production phase
then you may want to go for deep
learning but sometimes this is the only
thing that would work because you don't
have enough resources on the device to
do reconstruction
so for example if you want to do
reconstruction these are done by
by heavier hardware so if you want to
work at edge you're forced to do that
um but if you're if you have the time
then the question is that how much you
want to compress so i think if you
really want to go to the extremes of
compression and time you would be forced
to to work with deep learning sometimes
but if you are in mri i'm not sure if
that's what you want to do maybe you
play with it but uh
i i don't know actually you should know
that better
so we can discuss later
yes